[Musique]
bonsoir petit ami
etes-vous sage
[Musique]
en tout cas nounours n'est pas très sage
lui il est bien bruyant ce soir j'ai
besoin de me prendre pas trop et bien
descend vite te détendre en compagnie de
thé petit ami qui vont être ravis de
faire du bruit avec toi
[Musique]
ok
d'accord
le puisqu'au europe
bobobo boum boum boum
boum
écoute nikaïa quelle drôle de bruit ce
sont des indiens qu'agent nous vite
[Musique]
c'est malin oh
je suis désolé il ya de quoi à tharaux
de gâcher un carreau cassé
vous inquiétez pas voilà le site rien
cassé
massa au point qu'à ses
débuts l'alp et ridules qui passe la
halle du trio la halle du triez la halle
du cerisier pas si
karine vanasse et une image aucun avocat
célèbre
blackberry y est la lbu trier l'alpi
trier qui s'y passe
l'un des foyers l'arbitré labitrie pas
[Musique]
je me détends ça suffit pour aujourd'hui
demain toujours avait-on revolver bon
ben on ne pas vexer bon alors tu nous
accompagne au lit
tu sais que j'ai un excellent vitrier
henri braun a eu beau
dominer ce beau de nuit mais petit minet
que peux-tu mindy dont on a pour des
chats mais c'était gentil bon alors
bonne nuit les petits poissons
damier allier mes petits enfants
mignons ça vous convient
pas nui gros mines est
décroissante à demain
[Rires]
oh
[Musique]
tu te dépêches vitrier vous n'auriez pas
encore ou à réparer par hasard si notre
nuage suis-je bête
évidemment n'y a pas de carreaux sur
notre nuage allons en route gros étourdi
bonne nuit les petits faute de boer eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]